[Music]
let's talk about this jokes has been
getting a lot of attention The Client
List
you you play a masseuse who goes the
extra mile to to uh fair to say yes
she's the client yes she does anything
she can to please the client yes it's
quite risque some of this errs there's a
scenes with whipped cream there's
handcuffs just a riding crop situation
with a riding crop wells lots of things
but a guy was the guy was on the table
and I just slammed a riding crop down in
between his leg how was that pleasurable
I don't know how that would be I don't I
don't know I was in a bra and panties
when I did it okay yeah so it's fun to
look at you before the pain yeah the on
the show there's this certain protocol
that it seemed like it came from real
life it was a reality with this kind of
situation which is the client who's
getting massaged has to ask for what's
commonly known as the happy ending they
have to ask for it yes we're not allowed
to ask them if they want it but they can
ask us for it is that I think it's real
I mean I just I just point I don't I I
mean I think I don't I've heard of this
I've heard of the I've heard tell of
this pleasurable ending to massage but
but I have not myself experienced that
I'm always with professionals me too no
I am gonna weigh in you're being quiet I
I have I
[Applause]
he is notorious so it's that massage
therapist is like a 40-something Israeli
man I've never they often say I'm
feeling tight in my upper groin and
thigh area yeah I would think that would
be thank you
I'm completely just having a
conversation here speculating but I
would think that if someone was trying
to hint at that they would say they'd
start off saying I'm really tight down
there and then they'd get more and more
specific and rather than say risk the
possible arrests or whatever we have in
our show the client list is it's there
is a list of guys who come in for that
specific thing so most of the people
that come in are coming in for that and
we would imagine there's some visual
cues yes when the massage has gone well
there's a yes and that's how we're
making this sound like it's a real you
hear about our show you hear about it
all there's really craft service and eat
a chip and then I come back and we
pretend that's your erotic experience
you know but you do hear I'm always
doing it this it's one of those things
I'm such a such a bumpkin that I never
know about these things for real and so
I'm always it's one of the things we
hear people say oh well it happens all
the time
are they really yes well where are they
there's some danger where on Rodeo
specifically is there parking
technology they Valentin just start at
one end and working right now yeah going
from store to store to get happy endings
start we're a footlocker